[Music]
so I think that a lot of I think a lot
of popular Natural History likes to
portray the animal kingdom in very human
terms and and also stories that are
popular seem to be ones where animals
are behaving like us they're providing
us with some kind of reassurance in some
way you know animals on television you
know tend to have nice nuclear family
setups and and I think that what's sort
of fascinating to me is that this sort
of desire to see animals behaving in a
nice moral Christian family values even
way is something that we've been
propagating for millennia I mean
actually trait can be traced all the way
back to the the beasts trees the
medieval beasts trees which were the
very first animal and encyclopedias if
you like and these books were written by
religious scribes and they all copied
one book which was called the
physiological astiz what that translated
as and that was written in the sort of
4th century and what they what these
books what the physiologic still is it
popularized Natural History and it took
it to the masses and it became a massive
bestseller I think it was second only to
the Bible hugely popular and but what
what the physio locust and the moth and
the bee stories did was to look for
moral tales with in animal behavior they
weren't interested in trying to tell the
truth about animals or enlighten their
audience about animal behavior or even
the animal kingdom they wanted to use
they believed that God had implanted
moral lessons in animals to teach us and
so the stories that they told about
animals which
a hugely popular we're all very moral
there were animals were good or they
were bad and they they taught us lessons
about what's sinful and what isn't and I
think that to a certain extent we still
do that today we are still peddling
these same myths to a very large extent
you know popular press and newspapers
they love to tell stories about how you
know there was something the other day
that went viral about a stalk that was
returning to its partner after many
years and showing this this this this
love affair and we love to see these
sort of heroic or very kind of Christian
stories being told in in popular popular
zoological stories in the papers or even
on television I think the risk of
anthropomorphizing animals in this way
is that we just will fail to understand
them we won't appreciate them on their
own terms for what they are to paint the
animal kingdom with a with a Christian
moral brush is to deny it in its all of
it sort of sibling eating you know blood
sucking corpse shagging glory you know
and the thing is is we we shouldn't be
afraid of animals to behave as they do
in these ways that are maybe even
morally repugnant to us they're not
there to teach us a lesson they're just
there to live their lives if we want
moral guidance we should be looking
inside of ourselves for that we
shouldn't be looking to a penguin for
example to tell us how to teach our
lives no but you're probably thinking
all penguins are really cute and they're
monogamous and they mate for life well
actually that's not true either penguins
are birds with small brains that live in
a very brutal environment they have a
short window in which to reproduce and
so they're flooded with hormones and the
male's particularly Adelie penguin which
is your classic little black and white
penguin
the males are pumped full of hormones
and so they'll basically have sex with
anything that moves and quite a few
things that don't move by dead penguins
so penguins nefarious sexual activity
was first discovered by a member of
Scots Antarctic team and he was so
horrified by what he saw that he encoded
his observations of penguins sexual
behavior in Greek in his notebook lest
they fell into the wrong hands and then
he in his diaries are absolutely
hilarious to read because he starts off
and he's there observing the Penguins
and he's like oh look at them they're so
lovely they're like little children
they're so cute and then after after a
few days with them he starts writing
about how there are gangs of hooligan
cocks whose passions seem to have gone
beyond their control and who are who are
abusing chicks before the eyes of their
parents you know and this sort of you
know thoroughly appalling sexual
behavior that's that's taking place and
of course this is this is just penguins
being penguins they you know they have
this very short window on which to breed
it just makes sense that they they're
flooded with hormones and they're
programmed to have you know fairly
indiscriminate sex so you know it's not
for us to to make moral judgments about
but um so so yes so penguins are what's
interesting about when when Levesque
came back from the Antarctic with his
observations on penguins he took them to
the Natural History Museum in England
who published the first sort of
definitive book about penguin behavior
but they refused to publish their sexual
behavior that chapter was not included
and instead it was printed up as a
separate document and circulated amongst
a few learned people who were able to to
cope with this and and stamped not for
publication and lost to science for a
hundred years because we don't want
penguins
to behave like that we want penguins to
be cuddly fluffy lovely monogamous sweet
little animals but they're not
[Music]